We have a voicemail number. That number is two
one nine two David P.. Sometimes I play voicemails
that have something nice to say, sometimes
voice mails that have something not nice to say,
sometimes voice mails with a political observation
or a question. Over the last couple of months,
we have been getting more and more and more just
vile, disgusting, unhinged attack voicemails.
And I'm going to play one of those for you
today. I don't do this lightly. I actually think
we need to understand the level of escalation
that we are likely to see if Donald Trump loses
and claims it was rigged. OK, because it is going
to be aggressively weaponized. Just listen to this
and imagine it 20 million times over. OK, listen.
Yeah, David, I just saw your video about
Rudy Giuliani and you going on that he's lying
and you're basing it on on what? You have no
facts that he is lying. The fact is that until
Biden is a crackhead in the Biden family is.
Corrupt criminals.
And this is facts and.
You're going on TV, right? You know, you talking
about. But in fact, you don't. So you should
either face what you say on facts and or
shut up because you sound like a little
bitch. And now I appreciated Trump 20. Loser.
So that is what I'm willing to play for you
because there's 10 others. We've sent to the
FBI because it's another level altogether.
And so when I do the show and I say I am
genuinely worried about violence in the real
world, if Joe Biden wins and Trump convinces his
followers that it was rigged. And unfortunately,
at this point, I think Trump could even
say nothing after the election. He said
enough before it that many of his followers
will react as if it was rigged. Regardless,
I do think we need to be concerned about violence
in the real world. I do believe that for the most
part, our systems will be able to deal with
it. But it but it is a real concern. And I've
been getting messages from folks all over the
country about the aggressive intimidation. They
are already seeing. And, you know, yesterday with
with Doug in my interview with Douglas Murray,
he said, oh, you know, we we things are crazy
because people can't disagree with one another
anymore. And of course, the implication for many
of these folks is that the left will not tolerate
anybody who is conservative. Look at the degree
of not just intolerance, but violent hostility
from Trump. There are plenty of people in the deep
red states, in deep red counties who are planning
to vote or have already voted for Joe Biden.
They are deathly afraid of telling anybody. So
it is a problem, but it is not the one way problem
that some on the right claim it to be. So very,
very scary stuff. Let's all do everything we can
to stay safe over the next five days and beyond.
On today's bonus show, the CDC has studied
mask wearing and has found that young people
are the most unlikely to wear masks.
We will discuss that and more. Uber
is now being sued because its star rating system
for drivers is accused of being racially biased.
We're going to talk about the allegations and
whether they hold up, at least superficially,
and then how a court might weigh the allegations.
And 80 million people have already voted. Texas
over the next 24 hours will likely achieve
more than the total 2016 voter turnout
in early voting, early in-person and mail in
voting. We are going to look at the numbers.
We are going to look at the party division. It
is incredible, the numbers that we are seeing.
Two ways to access the bonus show, become a
member at join Pacman dot com or become a patron
at Patrie on dot com slash David Pakman show.
I look forward to seeing you on the bonus show.